fabiano quiere lograr al menos 6.5
puntos en un importante torneo de
ajedrez él logra un punto por cada juego
que gana y logra 0.5 puntos por cada
juego que empate
escribe la desigualdad que representa el
número de juegos que fabiano debería
ganar
empatar para lograr su meta y los invito
a qué pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta escriban la
desigualdad en término de los partidos
que debería ganar representados con esta
doble en mayúscula y los juegos que
debería empatar representados con esta
de mayúscula para lograr esta meta vamos
a resolverlo juntos cuántos puntos
obtiene fabiano al ganar un partido
recordemos que los partidos ganados los
representamos con la letra w mayúscula y
los puntos que se obtienen cuando ganan
es un punto así que sería uno por w pero
podemos dejar la doble un solita no es
necesario poner el 1 y esto va a
representar los puntos
y ganas o por partido ganado
y cuáles son los puntos por empate bueno
los partidos empatados lo representamos
con la d y va a ganar punto 5
puntos por cada partido empatado estos
son los puntos por empate
2 x
empate
y esto representa el número total de
puntos los puntos al ganar un partido y
los puntos al empatar un partido y
suponemos que no hay puntos por perder
aquí al menos no nos los indican y
queremos que el número total de puntos
todo esto sea al menos igual a 6.5
puntos así que queremos que esto sea
mayor o igual que 6.5 puntos estos de
aquí si dijera que fabiano quiere lograr
más de 6.5 puntos aquí tendríamos otra
desigualdad todo esto tendría que ser
menor o igual a 6.5 pero nos dicen que
javier no quiere lograr al menos 6.5
puntos lo que es mayor o igual a 6.5 y
ya lo tenemos aquí está nuestra
desigualdad que nos pide en términos de
el número de partidos que gana y el
número de partidos que empata y esta
desigualdad necesita cumplirse para que
fabiano logre la meta que se propone que
es de al menos 6.5 puntos en este
importante torneo de ajedrez